stuff again
today we have an exclusive interview
with Sam bankman free discussing the
bankruptcy of his billion dollar company
FTX why he hates when people talk about
his love life and his massive donations
to political parties now since going
bankrupt and being accused of fraud
Sam's been mostly quiet but recently
that changed when he gave an interview
to a citizen journalist Tiffany Fong now
we've actually talked about Tiffany's
work on the show before last time she
released an Insider call of a different
billion dollar fraud Celsius this time
she's talking to Sam bankman freed and
since I know a lot about FTX hopefully I
can provide some context in fact
checking where needed because Sam he
lies a lot now we'll be talking to
Tiffany later but for now let's talk
about one of the biggest claims in the
call you might have heard by now that
Sam was the second largest Democrat
donor in 2022 which in addition to his
significant donations to news outlets
might have been one of the reasons that
he was covered so favorably with an
image of being the most generous
billionaire But ultimately Sam told
Tiffany on a call that this wasn't the
full story they do need a thousand
about the great citizens united being
literally the highest profile Supreme
Court case of the decade and I think
everyone's hospital when they talk about
campaign Finance for some reason efrac
is no one can possibly fasten the idea
that someone team practice actually gave
dark so I don't know all my Republican
donations were dark wow Sam is claiming
he gave Republicans the same amount but
under the table the citizens united
ruling that he's referring to it allows
people to donate so-called dark money to
influence politicians in other words Sam
wouldn't be required to disclose that
donation and the reason he wanted to do
it this way was so that basically the
journalists would like him more and the
reason was not a regulatory reason is
because reporting just freak the [ __ ]
out if you donate to a republican
Charleston liberal and didn't want to
have that fight so I just made all the
Republican ones darts all right there's
a lot to unpack here let's start with
the fact is this even true I I don't
know I have no idea he could be lying
Sam lies all the time for example anyone
remember what he said FTX was solvent
right before it went bust yeah so
because of that because I don't know if
he's lying I decided I'd try to verify
these dark money donations go figure I
couldn't because the money is it's it's
dark you're not supposed to be able to
find it but either way if he's lying
this looks bad for him but if he's
telling the truth it looks worse I mean
it shows you how cynical Sam was he
never cared about politics he cared
about power and perception that's why he
played both sides so he always would
come out on top and worst of all they
bought it the media loved him some of
them still love him and going back to
the part about trustworthy though this
is what's kind of hard about covering
Sam in general everything has an
asterisk or a question mark next to it
because unfortunately Sam is very biased
against not going to jail he wants that
to be the outcome here so everything we
talk about needs to be viewed through
that lens so for the next part of this
call I want to talk about an example of
how Sam lies and obfuscates the truth
because so much of it is about trying to
craft an image with Sam obviously we
just talked about how he tried to craft
an image of being this generous
billionaire but after the FTX blow up
well he can't be that anymore what's the
new image well instead of being a fraud
the new image is a a smart guy who made
an embarrassing mistake and you'll hear
that in how he answers this next
question which is essentially talking
about the back door in FTX which was
used to defraud customers and pay
attention to how he answers it mean I
feel like there's something about a back
door that allowed you to execute
commands that could alter the company's
Financial records without alerting
others something like that this was put
in place I think that was a Reuters
article
um
which made it seem like you secretly
were moving money in the background
wait and this is something that I would
be doing I don't know it kind of said
that SBF put like a secret back door so
that he was moving funds to Alameda and
it was undetected like this was
something that you put into place
potentially I mean that's how it read on
the article
well I think for things because that I
can tell you is definitely not true okay
I don't even know how to code is the
honest embarrassing after no I certainly
wasn't like building some back door in
the system I could barely use this
system
um
user interface perspective
um but I uh I literally never hoping to
code it all right so for any of us yeah
um so I hear me build the back door in
there and I don't know exactly what
they're referring to I find this
response to be so telling because Sam is
lying here while telling the truth I
mean it is technically correct that he
didn't build the back door in FTX for
Alameda but he wasn't even the person
accused of building it because it turns
out Tiffany had misremembered the
Reuters article it wasn't Sam it was
Sam's right-hand man Gary Wang who was
accused of building it now this is
obviously a simple mistake and Sam would
know what she's talking about who she's
talking about and that Gary had built it
but instead of answering the real
question Sam uses this minor slip up to
create a loophole for himself to dodge
accountability oh what I coded it no I
didn't code it I don't code that's
clearly a lie because I don't code at
all see this couldn't be true because I
don't code and he frames everything as
this Preposterous idea while full well
knowing that his partner is the guy who
built it and he uses it to dodge the
part of the story where he stole money
and springboards into the part where he
can sell his preferred narrative that he
just made an embarrassing mistake well
they try and give you the nearest
neighbor to that so like the thing that
is true that like Smooth resembles that
statement
which is that um uh there was a stuff uh
long and I was wrong I didn't correct on
elevated balances on FDX by a seriously
large number an embarrassingly large new
one and it was because of a like very
poorly labeled the accounting thing
which was a historical artifact of a
time before when like from before SKS
bank account and the result of that was
basically there was a time way back
Yonder when people would wire money to
Alameda and then actually credited on
FPS that is basically never got screwed
up and that was like a pretty big uh
yeah I meant that Alami was like
substantially more lovers than I thought
it would I don't know if that's what
that comments talking about but that's
the best thing I think the sort of
closest thing I can think of for it this
is the image Sam wants to sell you one
where he didn't steal money he just fell
prey to a mistake a historical artifact
an accounting error honestly sounds like
it could happen to anyone you forget you
had that number in the spreadsheet and
oops it turned out to be eight billion
dollars of your customers money now he's
not explicit about what this accounting
error was but I can guess based on what
he said because back in the day FTX
didn't have a bank account for customer
funds so they had customers wire money
to Alameda research their sister company
instead of FTX and FTX would then just
credit that money to their customers
accounts so I'm guessing Sam's
explanation here is that they mislabeled
those incoming funds to Alameda as
alameda's funds and then somehow forgot
that they owed those FTX people their
money it's just a number on a website
somewhere when they go out to cash it
out all of a sudden it's like well Oh I
thought that was alameda's money that's
the strongest defense I can maybe think
of here that oh we had this complicated
accounting system that was confusing and
we screwed up oopsy-doopsy we lost eight
billion dollars and crucially you'll
notice that Sam's explanation requires
no amount of fraud or stolen money it's
just a poorly labeled account it's an
embarrassing mistake and we even saw
this end up on one of Sam's internal
spreadsheets as a quote hidden poorly
internally labeled Fiat account which he
says actually explains most of this
story this whole long Saga
okay and then there's like a dumb gay
count that we've labeled confusingly
it's four years ago and that was like
two-thirds of the whole song now this
has to be one of the most transparent
dog ate my homework excuse just in the
world of High Finance you know I
mislabeled an account I I just
accidentally labeled your money as my
money
oops sorry guys lost eight billion
dollars there didn't mean to do that I
mean again this is me reading into what
he said here about why he lost it we
still don't know exactly what this
internally labeled account is I'm just
trying to give the best explanation from
the available evidence but either way
Sam claims that even despite all of this
the real mistake was actually declaring
bankruptcy in the first place because
without it well things would kind of be
fine I'm like
right now
right now and not just us International
as well and uh I might still get there
we'll see I don't know it might happen
it might not but I uh
two minutes after I filed for bankruptcy
four billion more payments
um are you able to add it to the estate
I'm working on it but the current
Trustees of the state would rather burn
it all to the ground out of steam and
it's time to find a way to bring more
value to customers so right now it's
like in a jurisdictional battle between
countries over the band Garcia's all
right a lot more to unpack here Sam
claims that FTX and FTX us would have
basically been fine had he not filed for
bankruptcy because he got four billion
dollars in liquidity minutes after
filing now the problem with this is that
we just have no evidence any of this is
true and given all the past claims of
Sam that have proved to be wrong like
his solvency I find this very incredible
it's very convenient when you think
about it that oh we got a bailout right
after I can't help anything anymore and
that those darn bankruptcy lawyers just
want to burn it all down somehow I doubt
that anybody would turn down four
billion dollars for customers but that
appears to be the story Sam's sticking
with in addition to this Sam also
insists that FTX is not as bad off as
people say here's him responding to a
claim that users will get almost nothing
from the bankruptcy well I mean not
nothing like I think sorry there's
that's not counting like just liquid
assets that are there and I think if
nothing happens if I can never do
anything get into their own prices
eventually us will get a penny on the
penny a dollar on the dollar once they
get around to admitting that and an
international get found like 20 25 cents
all the dollars so I don't know exactly
what something like that now these are
just more wild lies from Sam
specifically about the part about FTX
International which is hopelessly
insolvent he claims it only needs four
billion dollars but that's not true the
only way he arrives at this number is
because he's counting billions of
dollars in coins that FTX has as real
money while football knowing he could
never sell that so I find this to be
kind of dishonest because like if I
create coffee coin and create a billion
tokens sell one of them for a dollar
technically my market cap would be a
billion dollars uh but you'd be a fool
to actually believe that's what I'm
worth but that's essentially what Sam's
doing with his own balance sheet he's
treating these coins which he owns the
majority of as if he could sell them at
the current market price which everyone
knows he can't and this denial also
extends to his own coin ftt which is the
native token of FTX which used as
collateral to get these loans now Sam
says is probably a mistake to use them
as collateral but he argues that ftt was
really valuable although hearing him
explain how is pretty interesting I
think FCU is basically more legit than
most tokens in some ways like I think
it's his value is more economically
underpinned than the average uh
you know than the average spoken was
that being said
um why do you feel that way strong
uh oh it's like Divine burning like you
know it's not it's not just like a token
that that like does nothing but you
can't at least he does something now I'm
kind of speechless here Sam seems to be
suggesting that his token doesn't do
nothing therefore is justifiably worth a
billion dollars this is despite the fact
that he created it from thin air and
owned most of the tokens uh it's just so
insanely cynical in my opinion his real
justification for its use case is only
these by and burns he did with the ftt
token which is just basically where FTX
spent money to buy up a bunch of ftt
tokens which they owned most of so it's
literally arguing that pumping your own
price makes a token valuable I I don't
know it's akin to saying my Ponzi is
better than your Ponzi because I pump my
own money back into it sometimes I I
don't know it's ridiculous and it
reminds me of a video we did six months
ago where Sam described everything as a
Ponzi scheme well it seems fitting that
he actually created a Zone token with
similar Ponzi nomics with a few extra
bells and whistles I suppose now funny
enough after this long call spent
dodging or being duplicitous about his
responsibility of fraud here Sam
complained about reporters not being
interested in the real story the boring
story and he said that he's tired of
getting questioned about these
provocative questions like his
relationship issues the problem is that
at the end of the day their metric is
quick like that's what they need to get
and it's fine it is what it is but like
what it means is that like a boring
story won't tell and so they're going to
be trying to ask me like the most
provocative possible questions I kind of
felt like all right like we as a society
have in my opinion my humble opinion
spent about enough time this week
trying to figure out
whether anyone in
uh living in Albany with polyamorous I
found this answer really amusing since
he's the one who's been dodging hard
questions this entire time and then says
no one wants to hear the real story and
also then brings up his personal life
and says why do people keep asking about
my personal life like wait a second you
just brought that that up so I find it
really weird to be complaining about
nobody wanting the real story and then
not answering hard questions about back
doors and instead talking about your
relationship I just thought that was
really funny now so far I've spent a lot
of time talking about Sam's credibility
or lack thereof but to me this all begs
the question what can we learn from Sam
who's so calculated who's so intent on
building this reputation or this image
of himself and he just isn't a reliable
narrator and I think the only honest
answer is that we can see how flawed and
warped his reality really is because in
Sam's World he's still the good guy he
just made an honest mistake an
embarrassing mistake sure but an honest
one it's the lawyers who screwed him who
want to burn things to the ground he's
standing on the sidelines with four
billion dollars that no one's seen ready
to put it all in to save everyone if you
only let him sell you his Ponzi tokens
on the way out it'll all be fine
but we know the truth things are not
fine at FTX reality has finally barged
its way into the Bahamas and it's taking
hold so I want to wrap this up by
speaking to the person who's responsible
for this interview Tiffany Fong I wanted
to ask how she even got this interview
since so few people have been able to
speak to Sam I was surprised that he was
willing to chat with me too I'm not a
traditional journalist or a reporter I
literally only started posting about
crypto at the end of June because I lost
a lot of money to Celsius Network so I
mostly started posting on Twitter and
YouTube just to vent but a few months
into posting Celsius employees started
sending me leaked information like
leaked files and leaked audio one of
which was a leaked internal All Hands
meeting that I posted on September 13th
to the public and I think you actually
briefly covered that in one of your
videos but Sam bankman freed started
following me that day so we had a couple
of free friendly exchanges on Twitter a
couple of them I think are actually
Republic so our DMS were already open
when FTX filed for bankruptcy on
November 11th so I just figured I would
shoot my shot and see if he'd be willing
to chat with me I really was not
expecting a response from him but a few
days later on November 16th he said he'd
be happy to chat and he actually
suggested a voice chat so that's how all
this came about and it's all still kind
of shocking to me as well that's so
crazy because basically you're one of
the few people who got a call with Sam I
don't think he's spoken to many other
people definitely no one else that I
know of on audio so I understand that
you'll be releasing the full call
yourself on your YouTube channel but you
know how long is it how long is this
call where can people learn more about
you the call should be about 20 minutes
long I did redact some of the parts that
he explicitly told me not to repeat but
yeah I'll post a call on my YouTube
channel because I think that a lot gets
lost on Twitter threads so for sure for
short guys be sure sure to go check out
the full call on Tiffany's page I'll
link both of her Twitter and YouTube on
uh in the description below that's all
for now thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one